hallow the Catholic prayer and
meditation app is recruiting Knights
Templars who are on par with 33rd degree
Freemasons to pray with Christians and
they are also recruiting Jesuits to do
the same Jesuits are just another secret
society so is the Hallow app really a
Sanctified tool to come closer to God oh
F
yeah hell yeah minicipal
week or is it perhaps a Jesuit Trojan
Horse purposefully designed to destroy
your relationship with Jesus let's take
a
look hey real quick so in this video
we're going to discuss a religious
entity a religious system that a lot of
people follow and are a part of we are
in no means attacking the people that
are part of it there are many really
beautiful genuine people who adhere to
this religion but we are talking about
the system and those who are head it
okay so let's dive in Hall app Scotty
have you ever used a hall app I have not
but I've seen a million of these
commercials yes me too that's why I
became interested in it now um Stephanie
you are a former Christian Mystic which
means you kind of dealt with some of the
prayers that were done in the hall app
correct yes everything on the hall app
almost I was familiar with and and did
so that's why we got you on board for
this show Hall app so I I saw the ads
like you right and saw a bunch of them
and I was like you know what I'm going
to look into this I'm going to download
the app to see what it is about so hello
is a meditation app it was started by
Alex Jones he said that he was feeling
far away from God and wanted to find a
way to come back come closer to God
that's a good Noble reason to do it I
was going to say that's why I did it I
really desire really relationship with
Christ with Jesus Christ yeah so that
sounds like a good thing to do right
like you want to come closer to God and
that's why you you download an app like
this and this is how it's also promoted
to bring you closer to God I I I also um
you know I want to
say uh this is th this is a difficult
thing I think to to um to think ill
thoughts of right off the bat I mean the
same as the chosen the chosen be good
yeah because you're like okay surely
this is like pointing people to God you
want to be really cautious and slow just
to call everything else out that's bad
so um I'm actually interested to learn
about this because I have never really
truly looked into this the the only
thing I know about hallow is like
hallowen that's the oh interesting okay
okay so so this guy Alex Jones he says
that he was looking for a deep and
transformative contemplative and
meditative prayer techniques this is
what's part of the hall app okay okay so
if you know anything about meditation
and contemplative prayer which Stephanie
knows a lot about this should get your
alarm bells ringing so right off the bat
is is he a is he in part of the Catholic
Church yes he's Catholic okay so he's
he's kind of maybe into some of these um
disciplines from osus Lola okay yes oh
you mentioned the name already here's a
couple of uh things that they talk about
what it is right it says he decided
mindfulness meditation the only type of
meditation I was aware of from Eastern
interesting Eastern Traditions okay so
like the way we know meditation from
yoga and all that kind of stuff okay
Stephanie give me a definition of
mindless mindfulness meditation what is
that well meditation simply has to do
with emptying your mind in terms of what
the app wants you to do and what we
learned in contemplative prayer so you
empty your mind you get everything out
of the way nothing between you and God
so that you can hear the voice of God so
the intention is really pure mindfulness
is kind of the gateway to contemplation
or meditation so it's just being present
where you are some people will use their
breath they say start with notice your
breath notice your body wear your arms
the position of your arms so it's just
being very present but in this noticing
you're slowing your thoughts you're
slowing your body down and you're
preparing your mind to enter into the
alpha ways of contemplative prayer got a
interesting point yes and especially
since he says this is where he got it
from he basically he's like well this
this is something that I I was doing but
he says I felt like I had to force fit
my Christian faith into an agnostic or
Buddhist box but then here all on the
right he says well Krishna meditation is
is something we can do essentially we
find a quiet place to sit and try to
focus our mind on something holy this
might be a phrase such as Come Holy
Spirit Spirit the rosary or an image of
God leading you beside a stream it's a
practice it's very similar to the
mindfulness meditation that Stephanie
just talked about but the difference is
that we use to simple focus on the
breath only to collect ourselves and
then turn our minds to God so in essence
this is what they want to do with the
hall app it has the Catholic label on it
but Stephanie you're going to go into it
a little bit later even more so into
contemplative prayer mindfulness prayer
lots of the prayers in this app and how
it shows you like you told me Stephanie
it pulls you away from God it does they
say in here it turns you to God but when
you empty your mind and you go into
Alpha wave you shut down your frontal
lobe the very place where the Holy
Spirit can speak to you convict you give
you discernment so it's going to be
another voice we're going to hear as we
will see as we progress in the program
so this is where things got really
interesting to me you mentioned him
earlier Ignatius of Lola Ignatius of
Lola he is the founder of the Jesuits
and I'll look in just a second about who
the Jesuits are because we did a whole
show um where this good friend of ours
good friend of the show James Bowen went
through all of the doctrines historical
documents showing you who the Jesuits
actually are and in fact that they are a
secret society put up by the Vatican but
ignacius of Lola founder of the Jesuits
he they have his prayers in and this is
directly from their website it says they
have the examine prayer which is a
technique developed by St Ignatius of
Lola found of the Jesuit order renowned
spiritual director and so let's take a
look at who these Jesuits actually are
this is a snippet of our show we did on
the Jesuits some of our viewers may have
heard of the extreme Jesuit oath it was
part of the Library of Congress due to
some uh political strugg that took place
back in 1912 between Eugene bonniwell
and Thomas Butler and this oath was
brought to to light there have been many
people that have claimed that it was a
forgery based off of some forgeries from
a fellow by the name of Robert wear and
it was classed with another document
called the secreta Monita that uh was
the secret instructions of the Jesuits
this second document right here was
originally discovered in the Jesuits
College of pbor West philia in a
cupboard in the rector's room and a
second second copy in the city of Prague
in 1611 now gretzer one of the Jesuits
affirmed that the Monita was a forgery
and the problem was is later on there
was a work found in the British museum
tucked away from 1596 20 years before
the alleged forgery in which the secreta
Monita is copied and it was very
scandalous in that it it showed a lot of
duplicitous means that they would use to
advance their cause and obtain means for
the order and so it was it was very much
a scandal for the order and as well as
this Extreme Oath and I'm not going to
read all of this here because I I'm just
going to challenge the viewer to maybe
take a look and see what kind of uh what
what kind of means they would promote
but it was very violent in talking about
you know attacking and killing people
and it's pretty gory yeah it might be
too hot for YouTube yeah I mean it the
one line really kind of you know stands
out there in the middle it's like do
further more promise and declare that I
will when opportunity presents make and
wage Relentless War secretly or openly
against all Heretics Protestants and
liberals as I am directed to
okay that that that's an interesting
point like that they're they're fighting
against Heretics Protestants and
liberals MH I mean I don't know you just
hear about the liberal mindset and and
and I I I think that they're talking
about a political group though right not
necessar assume so yeah yeah it's wild
have a social justice agenda so they
perpetuate that which they want to
undermine and you notice you don't see
the word fundamentalist here you see
Protestant but really they're after the
fundamentalist at this point the people
who believe in Solo scripture are still
mhm yeah and and if this is coming from
an order within Catholicism right I mean
this is like like anyone outside of this
mindset is is in that same camp yes so
it doesn't matter if you believe in
Jesus God is conservative liberal I
don't care about it I mean they're
willing to do the same thing to both
sides of that as long as you are not
part of their team yep yeah so the
Jesuits basically came about um during
the time of the Reformation the Dark
Ages when the Protestants came up Martin
Luther
zwingley um Huss and and and Drome they
came up and they said look we you're not
allowing us to read the Bible for
ourselves in our own language
why are you um doing this and and and
controlling the people and controlling
people's mindsets and and understand
like they the Roman Catholic Church was
super rich they took in a bunch of money
because they were teaching the pro the
Catholics or the Christians at the time
because there was only one church that
you had to pay for your
great-grandfather because he was burning
in Hell forever but if you pay a couple
of money which could be your last dime
then then um he would go to heaven you
know all those kind of things or you
have to worship all these statues and
stuff like that and they would make
money that way so they were pulling in a
lot of money and they didn't like that
they were losing control because these
Protestants were standing up saying we
want the Bible in our own language we
want the scriptures we want to read it
for ourselves and so many of these
things that you are teaching us are
incorrect that's when the Roman Catholic
Church put in the Jesuits the Society of
Jesus when in actual fact if you read
their oath that we have right here it
says that they were doing the most UN
Christlike thing such as I'm not going
to mention it for the sake of burnway
boil filt I mean strangle Berry those
are pretty heavy words exactly you do
all those things to anyone who doesn't
follow what we believe and so if you
watch the whole episode on um the
Jesuits that we have out there that's
where we're going off of look it up for
yourself this is history they it's in
their own writings what they want to do
and they're basically wanting to turn
all the Protestants back to the Roman
Catholic Church that they believe is the
mother church but Jesuits are a secret
society they are underground they're not
always publicly saying the Jesuit and if
they are they look like they're doing
all the good acts because they're
supposed to infiltrate the Protestant
churches to turn them back right and so
this is aati of Lola who teaches these
kind of things he founded the Jesuits
and this is in the Hallow app that's
pretty gory to me wow and this is what
they're teaching people so wait a minute
they put this in the hall up are you
just say Okay says oh no cuz this is too
hour right this is this is actually a
hard to find document sure sure you know
but but Ignatius of Lola's prayers and
he's are in there and he's promoted in
it and we're going to keep looking to
see how the Jesuits are absolutely being
promoted in the in the hall app so here
is another one St acius surrender prayer
shares this greater purpose of examine
with us so another Prayer by stus of
Lola now who was St Ignatius of Lola
let's take a look again an excerpt from
our episode with Jesuits there story
though began back uh much earlier uh to
ignacius lyola himself he was born Inigo
Lopez in lyola In the Castle of lyola he
was a colorful character Brash ruly and
unruly and easily offended he was born
to a wealthy family the police records
of the day said that he was kind of a
violent and vindictive fellow it's kind
of interesting to see though how he's
portrayed today very different from what
the the historical record indicates he's
very much popularized you can take a
look at that right herea is L I say we
[Music]
fight he wants to become a pilgrim he
wants to go to Jerusalem and beg his way
there like the holy pilgrims of old but
he's Shola what will people
say if you could hear the voice of God
would you want to keep it
secret you know what this council is
capable of do you really want to die so
that Council right there was actually
the Inquisition he himself was brought
up on trial for being part of the
alumbrados which was the Illuminati at
that time but what happened is early on
in that Siege of Pamplona his leg was
shattered by a cannonball and ultimately
his dreams of a warrior kind of ceased
and so he found himself going to the
mountains of monserat to visit an image
and this is the monastery that's now
there in monserat it's it's very you
know uh well gilded I guess would be the
term to describe it but he spent three
days in confession an entire night
before this black Madonna statue and
committed himself to Mary he ended up
staying at
Mona and in Mona he spent 10 months in a
cave and in exhaustion had dreams and
visions and he had many fanciful dreams
he saw lights flashing he believed he
chased Satan like a dog with a whip and
uh but later on in in in
1534 him and six others mostly of
Castilian origin all students of the
University of Paris met in mmar 3
outside of Paris and pronounced Promises
of poverty chassity in obedience now
there are some things that took place in
his history very much occult uh in in
practice he was said to have some ult
Powers such as levitation and you know
other stuff that was Supernatural but um
you know guys is is Supernatural
levitation is that evidence of Truth No
No by uh Sola scriptura is one of the
statements that came out of the
Reformation which means by the
scriptures and the scriptures alone and
the scriptures do not approve of any of
that or prove that any of this is
biblical but didn't Jesus walk on
water so what's levitation you know
there's a difference Satan has
counterfeits for everything but you
don't hear about people levitating when
they pray biblical prayers no that's a
good point mhm that's a very good point
well and the other question is too is is
is were they was he really levitating or
was it just hisory story that came out
that he was L I'd never heard that I'd
heard all the other but I wouldn't doubt
it and we'll see why cool I I I think if
the devil really is in in in involved in
this you know what I mean a great way to
stoke the fire I mean think about it
there's no social media back then is you
do something like that you levitate this
individual and everybody's going to talk
about it I mean he's probably a master
of social media if you would so he knows
in his day what's going to fly this
around yeah so here's a quote from
Ignatius Lola this is from his book um
spiritual exercise and he says to be
right in everything we ought always to
hold that the white which I see is black
if the hierarchical church so decides it
for we believe that between Christ Our
Lord the bridegroom and the church his
bride there is the Same Spirit which
governs and directs us for the Salvation
of souls for by the Same Spirit and our
Lord who gave the Ten Commandments our
holy mother church is directed and
governed that's a great importance upon
the church there uh yes and what he says
is if the church tells us well the black
you see supposed to be white he says
we'll do it it's fascinating that Satan
uses this type of mentality when it's
like he got the Adam and Eve to sin by
basically doubting right not doing what
God says in his own world he is
implicitly wanting you to adhere to his
word his principles it doesn't matter if
I say it's black or white you're going
to just jump and say yes and you say if
I say jump you say how high I mean look
at that that's wild that was the prayer
of surrender that you showed a few
minutes ago I Surrender My Liberty I
Surrender I think my mind my will so
there it's a counterfeit to surrendering
our will to the Lord right but God only
deals in truth because he is truth Satan
is the author of confusion and he lies
so he wants you to believe he wants us
to believe his lies yeah absolutely yeah
so another prayer that scius St Ignatius
of Lola came up with is contemplative
prayer which is wild to me because you
hear this everywhere and Stephanie I
know you've talked about this many times
in fact you might recognize Stephanie
from a documentary called mystified and
she talks a lot about it and it wasn't
even a Catholic to introduce you to it
right it was somebody else yes it was um
Church of the nazarine a
chaplain yeah yes so you can see how how
ecumenical this is becoming how it's
really going uh all over here you see
this is also from the hall apps website
in addition to being the founder of the
Jesuits and being a champion of the
daily examine he also popularized a
unique form of contemplation called
imaginative prayer so wait competit comp
or compet how do you contemplative
contemplative prayer Stephanie give us
like a short like what is that sure well
if you are a contemplative you say
contemplative and it just simply means
to contemplate we are spending our time
with God spending time with Jesus that's
what they say it is spending time with
Jesus your friend in a very intimate way
but what it's just such a misnomer but
contemplate means to think on right same
with meditate think on and yet the first
thing they tell you is empty your mind
and then use a mantra then they may not
say the word Mantra let's say pick a
word or a word or two for me it was
Jesus I felt it was safe or imagine
yourself they engage the imagination you
can engage all your feelings your senses
in that scenario and just be present
with your Lord with Jesus which is which
is a really funny thing to do because it
takes out the personability of the
communication with Jesus you know what I
mean if you're literally just emptying
the mind and then you're just saying a
word like you know let's just say I pick
the word house house house house and
that just keeps me like closer and
closer and closer to him or whatever
right it's not a relationship really
it's not like a communicative thing that
is true but
remember they or they will tell you
thoughts get in the way they get in the
way of what God's trying to tell you so
just move everything out give him your
mind so that he can speak to you
uninterrupted and that's yeah it's it's
a mind control but yet you think that
you're just like Thomas keading was one
of the books that I read when I first
learned to do this and he would say
imagine your the things that pop in your
mind like a grocery list or your errands
or whatever like a little boat and it's
just floating down the river Let It Go
notice it and let it go don't hang on to
anything because then that gets in the
way so it's a way of freeing yourself to
be fully present with
God it sounds crazy now as I think about
it but that was my desire at the time
but I would always pray biblical prayer
and then where people would yield or be
quiet and listen that's where I inserted
contemplative
[Music]
prayer yeah I I you know I I think it's
very uh interesting that this particular
prayer that does this to you and to your
relationship with God was actually
founded by Jesuit and the whole purpose
to actually turn you away from God and
we see it here on the official website
of the Jesuits as well it says
imaginative contemplation is a way of
praying that engages your full person
your imagination your senses and your
heart St agous believes that this is
essential for bringing about interior
transformation by going beyond the
intellect moving from the head to the
heart and meeting Jesus there I find it
really quite something that they use the
word essential in other words if you do
not use contemplative prayer you are not
going to EXP experience into your
transformation you're not going to
become more like Christ right that's
some heavy words right yeah I totally
believe that I felt like as a Mystic I
was engaging in something that people
like you didn't and you couldn't
experience the most intimate
relationship that God wanted to have
with us so I really felt bad for
you yeah and and honestly maybe the
people who are involved with hallow even
the founder are super genuine I don't
want to put them on the spot and be like
oh you're just yeah you're just being
yeah uh deceitful like he might actually
believe this stuff and this might
actually be really real to him just like
it was real for you Stephanie yes and it
felt so good how could not have been God
or Jesus I was interacting with or
experiencing and here's a note when I
came out of this when I was convicted
that it was not of God and I came out I
went through a period where I didn't
feel anything so we'll get into this
later there's a reason for that that can
happen in spiritual formation or in
practicing contemplative prayer um you
can go through what they call the Dark
Night of the
soul and where you don't hear from God I
never experienced that until I came out
of it but that was my testing time I
know now I didn't understand that at the
time but each day almost each moment
every day I was having to redecide no
I'm not going to engage with that
because I wasn't feeling
anything so did I leave God that was the
doubt that was in my mind I stood
faithful to the conviction when against
my feelings and then after a couple of
months God
changed that and became so real to me
and prayers answered
in ways that I had not experienced all
those n years in spiritual formation see
God does not want you to only have this
relationship with them based on your
feelings and I think that when you start
to to begin to experience these things
and then your relationship is based on
how you feel about that particular
situation yeah you can easily be let LED
as or astray right you know and it's
like maybe God just has to kind of push
the reset button on you and make sure
that you're there for the right reasons
and are you really truly here because
you Faithfully intellectually want that
relationship with him you know not just
something that makes you feel like you
are yes I mean all of this the decision
to engage in contemplative prayer and
then the decision to reject it once I
was convicted both of those decisions
were born out of a deep desire for a
deeper relationship with Christ mhm
that's the thing A lot of people are
very genuine in this and we're not in no
ways no means hammering on the people
who are practicing this who don't know
any better we're making this show
because we care about these people and
we want people to have the opportunity
to decide for themselves do they want to
continue with this or are they saying
wow I know the truth now and I'd like to
have a real relationship with Jesus
according to the Bible and how he SE
sees fit so looking over here um they
all Hall also quotes Pope Francis and it
says according to Pope Francis who is a
Jesuit who consider contemplation the
salt that gives flavor to our day
contemplation is less a way of doing and
more a way of being and it even says
here on the hall app it probably goes
back to Jesus himself I doubt that it's
not in the Bible in any way that's not
in the Bible but just want to point out
there that they're even showing or
quoting Pope Francis to promote the idea
of contemplative I like how they add the
word probably it's probably probably
yeah we don't have any proof we don't
have any proof but we're just gonna say
it this is from Jesuits USA East Jesuits
hallow app Lenton prayer series on book
by Walter CAC now check what this says
and and see who's actually involved it's
Jonathan roomy it's um Mark Walberg and
it's various people that you see on
there as well that we'll talk about in a
minute but this is what it says this
lens the Catholic prayer app hallow will
walk through the life-changing spiritual
classic by father Walter cesac he leadth
me father cesac and he's a Jesuit was it
Jesuit priest and missionary who was
imprisoned for more than 20 years in the
Soviet Union first in solitary
confinement and then a Siberian gulak
he's especially beloved by the USA East
Province since he was a Maryland
Province Jesuit again a Jesuit he's
buried at the Jesuit cemetery and then
so it talks about all of this like oh
this he's guy he's a Jesuit and this is
he's been um buried at as a Jesuit
cemetery and um he's beloved by the USA
East Province of the Jesuits it says all
of that and then it says oh and by the
way the Lenton prayer series will be
guided by actor Mark Wahlberg Jonathan
roomy who placed Jesus on the chosen
father Mike Schmitz hosted a podcast
Bible in a year and some other people
you know it's like a like let's get an
actor because people like actors let's
get the guy that's like Jesus because
everybody's following this guy anyway
but I mean you wouldn't just like take
all of these people and for all these
people to say yes unless they have some
agreeance to this I mean right it's not
like they're buying into it it's the
same as like if I were to show up on um
a satanic podcast I'm a Christian yeah
or Buddhist or Buddhist or whatever I'm
a Christian that doesn't make sense for
me to just go do that because unless I
agree with it right and we'll see that
these people are in fact somehow
connected to Jesuits or they are Jesuits
or they are heavily promoting Jesuit
teachings and our ingredients to it and
they're all involved with this app and
the purpose like the reason why we
showed that both in the beginning right
from a jesuit's perspective is to bring
people back into the fold of Catholicism
right isn't that the purpose of it is
the purpose yes so so if this is heavily
promoted by and or like promoting Jesuit
ideas and has like even Jesuit people in
it in the app I'm going to make a a leap
of faith here that this is actually
something to funnel people back into
Catholicism I mean it wouldn't surpris
me using people that the public is
familiar with is another way to create
and Foster
loyalty so when your heart strings are
attached to these people and then you
bring them onto this platform and you're
being fed spiritual
things then that creates more of a
loyalty to well the hall app but then a
sensitivity towards Catholicism mhm mhm
yes very true this is also the reason
why we have a documentary out on the
Chosen and some Jesuit Freemason
connections to Jonathan roomy which
we'll look at later on as
well so Timothy Gallagher this is
literally my screenshot this is
literally me going into the app looking
at what they have right it says he's a
priest Retreat Master spiritual director
speaker and author who has written eight
eight books on ignation discernment and
prayer it is literally everywhere okay
so who is this person he wrote the
discernment of spirits and aign Nation
guide of of for everyday living He says
we must hold fast to the principle of
obedience for only in submitting to the
teachings of the church can we rightly
discern God's will in our lives I I I
just want to make a distinction here
because you know on a on a passive
reading of this that you may not be
thinking more of like what you actually
just read right when you say the church
right you're thinking oh this is the
body of Christ right yeah but they're
meaning like the church body like as in
the highest Authority yeah that meaning
the pope you know what I mean like yes
like why wouldn't you say Jesus you know
what I mean it's like the Bible yeah the
Bible or something like this like like
God's ways right you're saying that the
church so and and and history has shown
there's been some corrupt people that
have flowed through the churches every
church every church every denomination
just point out this church every single
church denomination on the face of the
planet because I try to explain it to
people like this too if you are dealing
in a Warfare situation right Satan is in
a Warfare situation he's Waring against
God who are you going to put your army
spending time trying to to flip right
are you going to go after all the
satanists and all the other people right
they're already on your side you're
going to go after the Christians right
the Legion of angels evil angels are
aimed at the true followers of God right
and what do they they follow the
scriptures yes they're Sola scriptura
yes this is the whole reason we have the
the Reformation in the first place this
is correct so so I'm just making a point
here that putting the trumping bad use
of that word but literally the the
iconic thing that you follow is the
church I think is bad yeah you're
following people you need to follow not
the scriptures you need to follow the
scripture or Jesus yes yes good point
and notice that church is capitalized so
that is a they're meaning the
papal
institution interesting good point yeah
very good point good observation then we
got Thomas
aquinus he predated the Jesuits by a
couple hundred years but he taught many
errors that were not according to the
biblical scriptures he died in
1274 but the Jesuits revived his work
and it's a bit of a strange thing here
they have this thing called pintes with
a
aquinus uh here's an Instagram post it
says you'll also have access to several
episodes on prayer and spirituality as
well as Bible studies to dive into the
scripture From perspective of St Thomas
aquinus and again who is involved with
this podcast farer Mike Schmitz we just
talked about him and Jonathan roomy and
here you also see a slide with Stephanie
what are we seeing on this slide like
what books are we seeing here well when
I found out about this from you I went
to his website and on his
storefront where you can shop he had
whiskey glasses for sale he had CS Lewis
books he had Chronicles of Narnia and
I'm not going to say too much but I I
personally don't see a connection with
Christianity in those books I see more
of an occult bent
so you know it's just seeing these
things on the website of his
it's just very telling to me yes
especially the alcohol like why are we
drinking Pines with this saint which you
can also see here right how do we have
the mind of Christ when we're em bibing
any of that oh he's also sitting there
in his in his chair smoking a cigar so
he's smoking he's drinking we have vices
the things that God wants to Deliver Us
from and then we have readings that are
just not supportive to a deepening
relationship or a
Sanctified uh journey in Christ This is
a quote from Thomas ainus uh here he
says heresy is a species of infidelity
in men who having professed the Faith of
Christ Christ corrupt its dogmas so the
question is what dogmas now let's look
over here I answered that with regard to
Heretics two points must be observed one
on their own side the other on a side of
the church on their own side there is
the sin where whereby they deserve not
only to be separated from the church by
excommunication but also to be severed
from the World by death well he is
saying those people who are Heretics
should not just be excommunicated from
the church the Catholic church but they
should die and what is a heretic anybody
who does not follow the Roman Catholic
teachings wow so you should die and this
guy is quoted and used in a hall app I'm
just saying interesting and attention to
that last sentence because we're going
to see that they say the Catholic church
has changed we'll see if they have or
not oh yeah good good point we'll go
into that in just a second and also if
you watch the Jesuits video you'll know
it hasn't changed now uh Liam niss where
oh where do we see Liam niss being
associated with uh any Jesuit media
perhaps let's take a look this is
silence Liam niss was also in Movie
silence which is about a Jesuit priest
who was a missionary and he was also
used for the Hallow app as you can see
right here of course we also have Mark
Walberg and Jonathan roomy they're both
devout Catholics but Jonathan Rumi is a
Jesuit and a knight's Templar on par
with the 33rd degree Freemasons well
that sounds like an interesting
statement how can we know that well
we'll let Jonathan roomy speak for
himself I'm wearing a mantle and a cross
with a little crown on it uh a knight's
cross uh 5 years ago I was uh kned by
the order the
solemn uh Sovereign military order of
the Temple of Jerusalem I lost my mind
there for a second um essentially the
knight's Templar which is what that is
if you don't know who the knight's
Templar is look at the structure of
Freemasonry the knight's Templar is
literally the top step it is on par with
33rd degree Freemason in fact you can't
get any higher well at least any higher
than they tell us you can get than a
33rd degree Freemason or a Knights
Templar so blavatsky said that the
modern versions of the Templars were
actually inspired and influenced by the
Jesuits to try to
christianize what the Templars actually
believe and of course especially those
flavors that are connected with free
masonry now when you have Freemasons and
Jesuits orchestrating and directing a
Christian movie or Christian series
infiltrating and now they are running
the world's largest most viewed
Christian entertainment of all time that
is alarming on his Instagram which was
dated in 20120 it says it was an epic
inaugural event and on behalf of my
fellow Templar brother and sisters we
are so grateful to have been a part of
it the guy who is stamping Jesus in
everybody's mind is literally on par
with the 33rd degree Freemason so the
Freemasons have a statement called
momento Mory one of the themes that
Freemasonry emphasizes is momentto Mori
which means remember that you will die
this may sound morbid but it is a
reminder that we should always be
mindful of our mortality and strive to
live our lives with purpose and meaning
the a of momento Mori has been common
theme in art and literature throughout
history so this is also literally
straight up from the Freemasons and then
I also say it is a reminder that our
time on Earth is limited and that we
should make the most of every moment in
Freemasonry this theme is woven into the
teachings and rituals of the fraternity
reminding members to live a life of
Integrity compassion and service SK
Scully myy and what does the free makers
call it momento Mory oh interesting
right hey let's look a little bit more
into the Scully Mo thing that Jonathan
roomy is wearing he has those rings on
all the time right everywhere he goes
all the time all the time skulls now we
could just say oh well he's just wearing
those rings and how do we and okay maybe
it's on par with the 33rd of G fre
amazing but it's just skull rings well
he says it himself that it means Scully
Mory just know it comes from a very
deeply felt catholic christian
tradition about
mortality and the need to recognize our
mortality and to cultivate a deeper
sense of Holiness in our lives today
because tomorrow is not guaranteed
that's in a nutshell what this is
momental Mori remember you will die we
will all die it's just a part of life
okay wait wait a minute the Freemasons
are like yeah momentum more this is our
Jam you know the Catholic is like yeah
this is actually our jam and then it's
like but wait but are you are you part
of both cuz you said you are MH
what and he wears it and then look at
his T-shirt momento Mory wow does it
again I mean he has so much of that
stuff yeah yeah and then when did he
post this uh around Halloween which if
you really look into it Halloween is not
even celebration of death it's
celebration of death and actually he
says happy All Saints Eve many of you
know of my Affinity for the Christian
meditation post it post its Roman
origins of MTO Mor which translates
roughly to such and such and such I I'm
yeah it is really interesting because
this this imagery that he's putting out
into the world that you know he's he's
basically playing this part of Jesus
people see him as Jesus I mean they walk
up to him when he's in the coffee shops
and stuff like this and literally start
confessing things to them they think
he's Jesus people when they pray they
close their eyes they see him as Jesus
so I think I think you know whether he
wants it or not you are really
influencing people with this imagery of
Jesus and then all of a sudden you've
got all this death all over you mhm but
that's really ref free I yeah I find
that crazy and then if you notice like
he doesn't actually have it on here but
he will often wear his um ring with Mary
on it and he wears it on his ring finger
Mary Guadalupe yeah yep ring wears it on
his ring finger and you know it's so
interesting they're so obsessed with
death you know death to self which the
Bible is too so there's a counterfeit to
this but then you in your own
mortality and Jesus says come to me and
live the whole focus of Jesus is live
salvation life in him eternal life if
you if if you have the son you have life
indeed right you know and it's like yeah
there's a lot of speaking about life
life life not necessarily death yeah
it's hope filled it's not
hopelessness
amen so let's look at it last little bit
here before we hand it off to Stephanie
to talk more about the ecumenicalism of
the hallo app and what these different
prayers actually mean and what it does
to you I want to look at the board of
advisors on Hall app there's four
different people that I highlight it and
all four of them have either connections
with the Jesuits or are promoting it or
talking about it frequently okay let's
look at Bishop Kevin C rhods first now
this is him standing with the Jesuit
Pope he attended the pontifical
Gregorian
University so this University dates back
to 1551 when St ancius of Lola together
with a small group of Jesuits
established in Rome a free school of
grammar Humanities and Christian
doctrine in other words the founder of
the Jesuits founded started this
University that this particular
individual attendant he is on the board
of directors for hallow
app also by the will of Pope Pas the nth
it took the name of Pon pontifical
Gregorian University in
1873 and we'll take a look at him in the
next slide so here it says mcgreevy's
narrative follows to convergence of
three main movements that constituted
the oddly successful work of the Jesuits
in the United States firstly after the
restoration
Jesuits were naturally loyal to the
papacy becoming significant supporters
of who Pope Pas I 9th in 1850 after a
2-year political Exile from Rome Pas
returned and urged the Jesuits to
establish a new journal civilta catala
the journal soon became the most
influential Catholic publication
combating the heterodox ideas
proliferating not only across the
continent but throughout the world
subsequently Jesuits assisted pasus in
writing the 1854 Declaration of
Immaculate Conception the 1864 Syllabus
of Errors and the 1870 Declaration on
pap infallibility they fty their fty
extended to Pope Leo the 13th who called
on them to defend the church in the
Roman pontificate so this Pope is super
Heavenly fault with the Jesuits and the
he said oh yeah that that uh University
in Rome that the Jesuits started started
and Ignatius of Lola started I want to
be named after me and so this particular
University is what this bishop went to
he attended this University this this
University is entrenched with the
Jesuits and he is on the board of
directors for hallow
H here you see another quote from Pope
Pas he says the Absurd and erroneous
doctrines or ravings in defense of
Liberty of conscience are a most
pestilential error a pest of all others
most to be dreaded in a state in other
words you should not have Liberty of
conscience it's a pest in the state W
let us tell you what to think yes
because the church has to rule over all
your thoughts going back to the prayer
of surrender where it starts out with I
Surrender My
Liberty absolutely it's so different
than Jesus right come let us reason
together like he wants this you know
this mind that is um you know thinking
mind not just a you know do as you're
told and and and and it's wild because
it's like God is asking for obedience
but he wants your obedience out of your
own will and your submitting to it not
just like literally blind observance you
know so the second Board of advisers
father Steven
gruno he is the CEO of Word on Fire it's
a Catholic Ministry and here you can see
that in 2023 he wrote an article about
St Ignatius of fola show you what's in
some of my bag here I got the Liturgy of
the Hours That Word on Fire puts out
that basically is uh you're praying with
the the world the universal church now
Robert Baron he is the founder of heart
on fire and there's this guy called
Matthew Levering he wrote a book about
Robert bearing and this is an article on
heart on fire by Matthew Levering right
so read what this says such a
perspective first became available to
the young Baron Baron again being the
founder of heart on
fire at the Institute catholique the
perie through the person of his doctoral
adviser Michelle Corbin a Jesuit
Theologian and disciple of Henry Dubach
nevertheless Corbin also taught Baron to
read who Thomas aquinus as a spiritual
Master as Baron says on the dedication
page of his first post to citation book
Thomas aquinus spiritual master
[Music]
so again Matthew Ling right went to this
um university studied under a Jesuit
Theologian founded heart on fire and
then who is currently the CEO of heart
on fire it is this guy Steve gruno and
Steve gruno also writes on the website
of heart on fire about the Jesuits and
ignatious of Lola so they're they're all
intertwined and connected here's another
quote from the same book where you can
see that he connects Matthew Ling
connects CEO of Harden fire Robert baren
with friends Jesuit Pierre tart the
chardine and Carl ronner okay and then
we got father Mike
schmidtz he is the host for Bible in a
year and catechism in a year which are
two podcasts and the he's a YouTube host
for Ascension a Catholic YouTube channel
so wait wait I now I want to talk about
this for a second because I know a lot
of people that are that are listening to
him seriously yeah oh just that whole
Bible in a year didn't realize that had
a connection to Catholicism it does yes
interesting so you'll see right here it
makes a ton of videos for Ascension and
here you see this description of the
videos in which he talks about who
exactly I highlighted it paraphrasing St
Ignatius of Lola and CS Lewis on the
other one St Ignatius of
Lola and these are these are just a
handful of videos that I grabb there are
more videos in which he talks about St
Ignatius of Lola he's talking about the
founder of the Jesuits wow and he is on
the board of the directors and of course
lastly he also wrote a book about
different quotes from Pope Francis in
which he specifically talks to young
people and again Pope Francis is of
course a Jesuit Pope
so pretty interesting stuff but that's
doesn't end the show right here because
now Stephanie again we introduced you as
a former Christian Mystic you practice a
lot of these prayers that are found in
the Hallow app you're going to take over
and you're going to show us the
ecumenicalism of this right because the
church denomination that is the most
ecumenical wanting to bring all churches
together but under their umbrella is in
fact the Roman Catholic Church which
totally suits the Jesuit agenda so
Stephanie is going to talk about that
and then she's going to talk about the
prayers that she had experiences with
and why it's so dangerous and how it
actually pulled her away from God so
what I'm bringing forward is the
football um the Super Bowl ad for Hall
app it was huge they gained a lot like
thousands of subscribers from this ad so
let's see what the ad
was God we take this moment just to give
you thanks we thank you for this time to
come together as a
family as
friends and as a
country help us Lord especially this
Lent to grow closer to you amen join us
in prayer this Lent on hallow stay
prayed
[Music]
up they they really hit a few like real
like emotional buttons right your
country your family you know
Christianity that we need this that was
there was a I I took a picture uh of
this recording and I th threw it on
Facebook and um yeah there's someone who
commented and they were like well this
is Christianity 2024 where we attack
good things like Christian things you
know because that's how it's being
portrayed and he kind of acts like no
this is a good thing we're connecting
with God and and people and you know
they're they're genuine they just don't
know
this is actually pulling you away from
the Lord what is the lint again what is
the ash thing it's a sign of
repentance okay yeah has to do with like
you know their Easter they balm Sunday
and Easter and they they it's it's just
an outward expression of their
repentance and they give up something
during that week um each for each person
is different so it's there's
a
um it's like a instead of cleansing your
life Allowing God to cleanse your life
you just give up something for a week or
for whatever that time period is so it's
kind of an
exterior um act rather than the internal
cleansing it's counterfeit
sanctification possibly gotcha it's like
I just kind of asked for for confession
but I can still continue forward kind of
a
thing
well well for that time period they give
it up so yeah and then you can go right
back to it I mean there that kind of the
idea is like if you give it up for that
week but that's the only week that
you're giving it up it's not like a call
to give up something forever right no so
some people quit drinking for a week
some people give up chewing gum for a
week whatever you feel like you want to
give up and God didn't say just give up
the sin for a week yeah so so now we're
going to talk about Sunday as being
changed by the Catholic Church it says
Sunday is our Mark of authority the
church is above the Bible and the
transference of Sabbath of observance
observance is proof of that fact and
that's from the Catholic record when we
move forward and we look at the history
of Sunday it celebrates the sun god raw
it says that in the year 321 ad the
Roman emperor Constantine rules that the
first day of the week the venerable day
of the sun should be a day of rest and
then it later became the Lord's
day so let's look at Raw says raw was a
god of the sun has has the head of a
falcon and the sundisk inside the Urus
resting on his head and it has a snake
around it as well it looks like that yes
oh and the snake in the Bible is is
considered a symbol of Satan so that
that's that's pretty crazy and if you
really look into all of these ancient
Sun gods they really are all uh a form
of worship to Lucifer MH so then he says
they say he identified primarily with
the Noonday Sun raw ruled in all parts
of the created world
the sky the earth and the underworld
this is interesting because in the Bible
uh obviously well Satan is considered
the god of the underworld that's that's
that means like in those Pagan cultures
it means hell and death and all that
kind of stuff but then also he's
considered in the Bible that he's taken
over how do you say it ownership of the
world from Adam and Eve when they fell
which Jesus regained through the cross
but then also uh somewhere in the Bible
it talks about how he fell from the sky
he was cast out of Heaven he fell from
the sky there's even a connection to
where he it says that he he was seen or
is connected to lightning and he's the
prince of the air Prince of the air and
and another thing to point out here too
is it says we're all ruled in the parts
of the created World it doesn't say he
created the world he's just ruling in
the world that's a good point and Jesus
Jesus said the ruler of this world so
and I also want to bring up um you know
in the Bible in Revelation 13 towards
the end in the chapter it talks about
666 I recently actually rewatched uh an
old video that we have on Christian
nationalism with Dr o and he pointed out
that 666 in the ancient Pagan religions
it might have been Babylonian or or
Mesopotamian I'm not entirely sure um
but that 666 was actually another symbol
of the sun wow and I was like whoa that
just puts everything together yeah Sun
worship I think that's that's just the
counterfeit right s o n is Jesus and you
know Su n is is is Satan
mhm okay so the symbolism is what I'm
wanting to focus on and that is if you
look at the Hallow app you see the same
raw MH and then you cannot you cannot
christianize it by putting on a Halo
yeah yeah exactly the Halo is a is a
sort of a a washing of something being
holy yes you know what I mean but if you
look at the origins of the Halo it's not
Christian it's Pagan right so I don't
know have you ever seen the documentary
Babylon the bride the Revelation the
bride the beast in Babylon great
document by amazing fact oh go watch it
Link in the description it talks all
about the ancient Pagan religions and
how it infiltrated Christianity and
Christianity even today is not as pure
or scriptural as it once was and we
should go back to the scriptures but
they point out that the Roman religion
right the pagan religion of the Romans
where they worship planets and the Sun
and things like that they when the
Romans became quote unquote Christian
they started blending their Pagan
religions with the Christian religions
and so they looked at the Statue of
little human with the Halo above it and
it was like oh this is supposed to
represent the planet planet of Saturn
like their God Saturn um but uh we're
just going to give it this Apostle's
name and now all of a sudden it's St
Peter or whatever but it had the Halo
and everything it's Pagan right
interesting they have it a discus right
it's they call it a discus for those the
Saints as millions of pagans hastily
joined the church they were naturally
reluctant to dispose of their Idol
Treasures the Romans and the Greeks were
so used to being surrounded by symbols
of their deities they began doing the
same thing with Christianity so many of
these new converts just relabeled their
Idols with Christian names like Paul and
Peter a statue of Jupiter became a
statue of Peter and we know that because
it has a sundisk right over its head
that indicates that this is not Peter
but it's a pagan statue that's been
renamed the representations of Isis
which is originally an Egyptian godest
but has become very Greek already
becomes essentially the representation
of Mary carrying her child you have a
mother and child tradition all the way
down through history uh you have it in
mithraism you have it in Babylon you
have it all the way back in pers it
appears that Mary acquired some of the
characteristics they were associated
with some of these other goddesses she
wears a dark blue coat and she stands on
the half moon she is the mother of all
gods is is carrying her son Horus that
is the image that gets a new name and
now the name is Mary carrying the Child
Jesus or a depiction of the God Hermes
is shown as Christ the Good Shepherd
soon the statues of the Saints and even
Jesus began adorning the
churches even though God clearly forbids
this practice in the Ten
Commandments people continue to rever
and to pray to these relabeled
Idols Thou shalt not make unto thee any
Graven image or any likeness of anything
that is in heaven above or that is in
the earth beneath or that is in the
water under the Earth thou sh shalt not
bow down thyself to them nor serve
them okay so if you look in the middle
of the screen you have Jonathan roomie
and another Gentleman on a stage where
it looks like it's a Catholic event and
above their heads on the screen what do
you see you see the sun disc disc with
the Rays around it and you have it on
the wand of the Pope he carries it
around as well mhm okay so I have here a
few Clips they're kind of strong to
together from people we all know um
athletes um and we also know Candace
Owen who recently converted to
Catholicism after a long struggle she
was Protestant she married a Catholic
and then she ended up converting and
went on a pilgrimage it was quite
interesting to hear her pilgrimage so
here you go let's see what they have to
say about the Hallow app all right guys
if you want to have a deeper prayer life
and you don't know where to start I
totally get that and so does hallow
which is why I'm excited to tell you
about Hallow's new prayer challenge how
to pray hey everyone Harrison bucker
here Super Bowl champion kicker for the
Kansas City Chiefs many people know me
for being a great athlete and a faithful
Catholic neither of those things come
without hard work and dedication just
like the countless hours I spend
practicing on the field we should be
working just as hard if not harder for
our Salvation that's why I'm excited to
tell you about hallow the number one
Catholic app in the world that brings
countless prayers and meditations at
your fingertips aside from praying with
me you can also join pro athletes such
as football legend Brett Favre my friend
Trevor Williams of the Mets and
countless others in our new athlete
prayer section to help deal with the
pressures of life and competition St
Hood won't be easy but it is absolutely
possible and hallow has made building a
daily prayer life that much more
attainable download the app today and
start growing more in Holiness to the
heights check out hallow because this
could radically transform your spiritual
life we love partnering with hallow
because they are truly not only the
number one app but they are the number
one provider of the history and the
legacy of Christian prayer and
meditation and contemplation to date
they have inventoried in their library
and their resource this application
we're talking about they have
inventoried so much content and some of
the top level speakers in the known
Catholic world today there's some good
meditation apps out there but I at least
wanted something Catholic we've been
doing mindfulness long before mind
mindfulness was a thing but many
Catholics have very little experience
with contemplative prayer thankfully
there's now a great app called hallow
hallow can be a great way to shake up
your prayer routine but with methods
that are right out of our tradition the
guided meditations give you Direction
but also leave plenty of time for
silence hallow facilitates wasting time
with God which of course is anything but
a waste I wanted to point out about him
it it just you know the fact that he
said that this is straight out of our
tradition and um you know the examples
that we have in the Bible of mankind
following tradition over other things
did not turn out well yeah and also the
athlete he was talking about working for
your salvation which is it's true that's
a Catholic belief or tradition that
salvation comes through works by uh
visiting Saints by paying penants by you
know doing things
sacraments exactly uh and really the
more money you give the more people you
can family members you can pull out of
purgatory and then Candace start ended
her segment by saying um they you can
learn how to pray with the Hello app
well I mean who who taught us how to
pray in scripture yeah right and Jesus
that vlogger that um that was talking on
on on the podcast where there's the four
of them on the screen if you notice they
had a little bobblehead of Jesus to the
of the Pope don't if you notic that yeah
but we're we're definitely putting those
two on the same level when you kind of
got that that that kind of a thing but
um I'm just thinking of the
ecumenicalism of this you know it's
everybody's talking about it um and I
mean I I I read some reviews of
Protestants that were using the app and
that were growing more fond of
Catholicism or had converted you're
seeing in our society today a a real
blending these two concepts
evangelicalism and Catholicism playing
together basically um obviously the
universalism is is is something that the
Catholic church is very interested in
and very invested in the ecumenicalism
of it um but you know the fact that we
have a president that is a quote unquote
Evangelical and a he's Presbyterian I
think but he hangs out with a lot of the
evangelic yeah but he isn't the
Presbyterian isn't a Protestant right so
you have a his wife is Catholic yeah so
you have a Protestant mixed with a
Catholic um and then of course the
chosen series you have oh sorry you were
talking about Biden I was talking about
Trump you were talking about Biden both
okay Biden is Catholic I don't know what
his wife is and Trump is I think he's
Presbyterian and his wife is Catholic
Trump I think yeah is some sort of
protestant right yeah okay so yes but
his running or his mate with him vice
president cathol is a Catholic and he
was converted from protestantism so you
see Jonathan roomy and you also see
Dallas Jenkins Evangelical cathol so
those two concepts are being married
together in the public eye see the
evangelicals we made a video about this
recently uh you see the evangelicals who
are gaining Power by trying to push
their agenda through Donald Trump and
but giving him votes in exchange but
then they are getting their agenda out
which really that's a whole different
story but it's a church State agenda
which and and they're hanging out with
the Pope as well the evangelicals um
okay so we have all these people who we
know and uh are familiar with and have
some sort of attachment to now telling
us to use the hall app so why wouldn't
we this is a video clip about um just
what you were talking about ecumenicism
when Jonathan the actor from The Chosen
sat down with Dallas Jenkins the
director of The Chosen with the director
of the Jesus Revolution movie the
discussion was very interesting because
you hear them talk about the
universalism or the
ecumenicalism of bringing all these
faiths together what what do you most
want people to get out of it when they
see this movie like you want them to
walk out of Jesus Revolution uh thinking
or feeling what what I would hope is
that this inspires their curiosity maybe
if they're from a different uh you know
denomination to kind of see that um how
how uh ecumenical this movement was uh
because it affected so many different
kinds of Christians that's the same
thing it's all it all they all have the
same agenda to reach all denominations
okay so here we go another little
ecumenical piece here I just want to
bring forward this is Jonathan roomy
with his Bible and the back of his Bible
has a rosary like an engraved Rosary
thing in the back and you can put your
fingers on it and do the rosary um and
this is a a comment from an Evangelical
who ended up joining their Rosary hour
he said was so moved emotionally he says
I knew it wasn't just Catholics on this
live stream yet there were there we were
all together praying so this is another
ecumenical
piece yep yep you know um I I also think
like you know people are responding
emotionally how this makes you feel when
you do this um you know I think there's
a lot of emotion that is involved in um
sort of some of these practices and and
that's what draws people to it and
also understanding what the Jesuits want
is their whole sole purpose of why
they're in existence is to infiltrate
Protestant churches Protestant
movements they don't even always come
out saying they're Jesuit because
they're they're a secret society but
they'll they'll do the acts they look
good they they they come to the
hospitals they will do good for other
people so they look like devout
Christians but then to pull your you as
a Protestant back to what they consider
the mother Church like that's their
whole purpose and that's that you see
that with the um ecumenical movement
like the whole ecumenical movement
really if you look at it it's a Catholic
movement and they're not saying we are
going to unite with all these other
Protestant churches and we are going to
change it's like being Baptist yeah you
need to become Catholic and you need to
join us and all of this is is is is just
another way of working the Jesuit
Society secret society and pull people
back into the the Catholic faith all
right so here we have a clip of Jonathan
roomy doing a live and he's talking
about another ecumenical piece you know
footage BTS stuff behind the scenes
that's what BTS stands for and uh show
you what's in some of my bag here I got
the Liturgy of the Hours that a word on
fire puts out that basically is uh
you're praying with the the world The
Universal Church
okay that
is universal right Catholic means
Universal yeah Universal is really just
something that like kind of fits into
everything I I think that's why you know
people don't recognize as well the miter
that the pope wears is a fish God deeon
hat these blending deeon religion which
goes all the way back to who was the
ones that Philistine isn't that
Philistines isn't that a Philistine like
God I think Deon was a Philistine God
but it's it's it's a god from it's a
pagan God that's from Ancient Ancient
and that's the top of the fish I mean
yeah it's it's a blending of all that I
like is I don't like his skull t-shirt
yeah he's wearing the the skull again
momentto Mory yep
Freemason all right so let's talk a
little bit about Vatican 2 um people say
that the the Catholic church has changed
so let's see if it's changed Vatican 2
is say the church revised the
traditional Divine Office into what we
know as the Liturgy of the Hours for for
greater use in public and among lay
persons so this is just talking about
the Liturgy of hours and how uh they
revised it what they did was they they
made um shorter readings per day so
they're giving you less of the scripture
or their words um again always taking
away so but this is just another eum
piece this is what I used when I was in
spiritual formation I was introduced to
this um I used it once or twice it kind
of wasn't meaningful to me I I like my
Bible so I read my Bible praise the Lord
yes so for some good things that I
retained right God is good he's
faithful so let's talk about
what the response is to um this question
on vatican.va says the first question is
did the second Vatican Council CH the
Catholic Doctrine on the church response
the second Vatican Council neither
changed nor intended to change this
Doctrine rather it developed deepened
and more fully explained it what was
still is what the church has taught down
through the centuries we also teach in
simple terms that which was assumed is
now explicit that which was uncertain is
now clarified that which was meditated
upon discussed and sometimes argued over
is now put together in one clear
formulation and again that's a Vatican
Source interesting what the church has
taught down through the centuries we
also teach well what did we talk about
earlier right what what is the origin of
the Catholic church it's Roman which
really goes down to Babylon and and it's
Pagan so if if you if if Catholic means
it became that though yeah yeah yeah not
the very beginning I know but that's
really the origin of of their teachings
right and if you remove if you change
Catholic to Universal cuz that's what of
means it literally says Roman Universal
Church there's nothing in there that
indicates Christian and and the reason
why Babylon is also ascribed to this in
the Book of Revelation right they talk
about the Church of Babylon a lot and
that that there's there's there's some
evidence that this is the church that
it's using but it uses the term Babylon
Babylon whenever it conquered um any of
the surrounding Nations instead of just
completely squashing them and snuffing
them out they sort of Incorporated them
on into the Babylonian society and so
they would take on their religions in a
universal way so it was like okay we're
just going to appease the people because
what are the best type of people the
people that want to be part of your your
kingdom right if you're constantly
rebelling you're going to constantly be
at war with people so they found that
the best way to suck them up into your
Society is to let them still have their
kind of traditional faiths but it's then
Blended together into this one thing
which causes confusion yeah Babylon
means confusion you cannot have yeah you
cannot have all of these faiths you
can't serve Buddha and Jesus at the same
time you can't blend those two concepts
together light or dark doesn't mix you
can't you can't blend Deon with you know
what I mean with other things like it
just doesn't work it doesn't fit like
that if you are a true follower of
Christ then you are a true follower of
Christ and it says have no other gods
before me there's there's no other God
religion that can be incorporated into
that faith and interesting that you
brought that up about incorporating
other religions so that you know they
would be okay with it to adhere to it
when Roman emperor Constantine became
Christian that's what he did he was like
okay now everybody this uh I believe
this Christian God gave me the victory
over this battle so therefore we're all
going to be Christian but then he we're
going to worship on Sunday because
that's that's what people did with they
were
and all these kind of things like I said
I had the pagan gods and stuff to make
it easier for everybody to become
Christian we're just going to blend the
two and just like like first you have
Sun worship on Sunday and you have the
the Christian Sabbath and that got
slowly wiped out and then we only have
Sunday and then we have the statues that
were Pagan and we make them Christian
it's the whole medle and mix that you're
talking about just absorbing them all
together which causes confusion yep and
what you were seeing played out today uh
it's called dominionism and that's how
the quote kingdom of God is expanded uh
they their perception or their teaching
is the kingdom is here and now on this
Earth well we know the Kingdom of Heaven
is in heaven right so they they expand
the kingdom down here by
accepting so they accept witches they
accept Buddhists they accept atheists
whatever into to and they then they it's
Embrace and expand Embrace and expand
and that is the kingdom dominionism all
right so Wayne Teasdale among says
interspirituality is a uniting of the
world's religion through the common
thread of mysticism the spiritual common
grounds which exists among the world's
religions so car ranner who was the
architect primary architect for Vatican
2 says this the Christian of the future
will be a Mystic or he will not exist at
all that last part of that is like a
Veiled Threat we'll see some
more of um this kind of sentiment later
but this is just like kind of the
beginning but this is what he says so
you will either be a Mystic or you won't
exist wow so that's a that's a that's a
heavy statement I just want you to like
sit and think about that for a second I
mean think about if that is a a a term
of you know you will be taken out if you
do not have this this perspective but
also does Christian and
Mystic intertwine I mean I know
Stephanie used to be Christian Easter
and Christian yes but what is the
mysticism actually it's paganism it's a
cultism right and Christianity is not
that but then if you understand the
origins of the Roman let me say
universal church then it is all Pagan
and Mystic and if their purpose of the
Jesuits is to bring everybody body back
to Rome back to the Roman Catholic
Church then of course they're going to
say the future is Christian and Mystic
or there is no future at all either
you're going to subscribe to our mixture
of Christianity and paganism and
occultism
or which brings you to worship or die
yes yes that's that's that's a very deep
statement and the whole purpose for
contemplative prayer is to bring those
into mysticism
so if you're a Christian you're not
going to accept meditation well they do
now a lot of them but uh traditionally
we have not taken on these new age kinds
of practices so they just put a
different label on it called it
contemplative prayer brought it into the
church so now the common denominator of
mysticism is contemplative prayer we saw
that in the Hallow app ad uh where this
or I should say the the priest who was
talking about the Hallow app and he says
we've been practicing mindfulness and
meditation for
thousands of years for a long time
before was called this and this whole
hallow app is a prayer and meditation
app yeah and then who brought in
contempla prayer Ignatius Z Lola who's
the founder of the Jesuits yeah I'm a
self Mystic as well yeah yeah he's a
Mystic wow uh and just I want to touch
point with the new AG right here
Christians forth new ag.org says that um
well they suggest breathing or
techniques often include uh breathing
exercises visualization
repetition of a word or phrasee
Detachment from thinking these are all
the things that we have discussed a
little bit and that the hallette path
breathing exercises guided meditations
visualizations repetition that's your
your um well it's your Mantra kind of to
begin contemplative prayer and it's also
the prayer beads we talked about and the
rosary and then Detachment from thinking
which is full-on contemplative prayer
which is what the judgments Jesuits use
so no different than the new
age all right so from hallow app we have
from uh there quote essentially we find
a quiet place to sit and try to focus
our mind on something
holy this might be a phrase such as Come
Holy Spirit the rosary or an image of
God leading you beside stream beside a
stream this is imagery visualization
this is
repetition um and for me I just used the
word Jesus because I thought it was safe
and I imagine envisioned myself sitting
in a forest kind of on a tree log with
Jesus sitting beside me they also say
it's a practice that's very similar to
the mindfulness meditation but the
difference is that we use a simple focus
on the breath only to collect ourselves
and then turn our minds to God the best
part of Christian
meditation uh is that we are we are not
the ones doing the work and we truly
aren't by the time we put ourselves in
this Alpha State there's another spirit
that has access to it do our minds but
you notice the breath they do their
cleansing breath basically is what it is
and then they move into contemplation
but see where it says they turn our
minds to God uh most times you'll see we
need to go
inward but when they turn their minds to
God they're in Alpha so they're they've
just blocked the holy spirit so here we
have a little video from the hall app
let's see what it says hello and welcome
to hallow
hallow is a Catholic prayer and
meditation app that combines the peace
and Stillness of meditation with the
spiritual growth of contemplative
prayer You Begin by setting your own
goals whether you want to focus on
learning the basics of prayer dive
deeper into meditation pray with
scripture listen to prayers before you
sleep or anything in between you can
select which areas you'd like to
explore did you hear her tone of voice
she was very like soft and kind of
lowish and
monotone I wanted to go to sleep yeah
very very low level of instructions um
when you look up the definition of
hypnosis in Webster dictionary even some
other dictionaries um they talk about um
hypnosis as being a uh an amount of
instructions on a low-level voice and or
using a low-level voice in in giving
instructions and she's saying you know
do this do that and is very monotone was
listening to a book recently by Lee
Strobel he he is was an atheist his wife
became Christian and he used his his
legal and his journalistic background to
research the case for Christ like you
know from a
scientific point of view from an
archaeological Point of View Medical and
psychological Etc and he was
interviewing a psychologist to discuss
whether Jesus working miracles was
actually Jesus you know hypnotizing
people and the psychologists obviously
debunk that through science that he did
not do that they were real Miracles but
he said the way people do H hypnotize
people is to talk with this kind of tone
of voice so that's coming from a
psychologist who understands this yep we
have a clip to who kind of somebody who
explains the same same something very
similar and then she demonstrates it so
let's see if it sounds like what we just
listened you just relax and imagine all
your attention drops into your womb and
your voice speaks from
there it
changes and then you lift it up this is
from
stomach this is from my heart and this
is from my throat just a normal
conversations anything you say Speak Out
hypnotically magically your own voice
has so much power power over your mind
you'll be shocked but also try if you're
going to meet up with your
friends
yes and then what happen three-step
frame now I will go make your cup of te
we'll have a
Cy you'll
relax and you'll tell me all about
it what just happened
you w you woke up hypnotized you know
you know that makes me think of little
mowgly from the thing when the snake
wraps around him and look into my eyes
and his eyes are going woo woo woo woo
Jungle Book wow yeah I mean there's
something hypnotic about that that's why
a amsr like people love that kind of
stuff yeah it's just that quiet thing if
you speak like that it does something to
our B I like how she said there's a lot
of power in the voice mhm I mean God God
made us in His image he has power in his
words he formed us on the ground but but
but yes he spoke many things into
existence yes creation into existence
but yes he formed got on his hands and
knees and formed Man Out of the Dust of
the ground but but yeah she's she's
recognizing there is power in our words
the Bible tells us that life and death
is in the tongue right exactly y so for
me when I first listened to that the
little blurb from hallow app my it
triggered my mind because of my
contemplative background I am more aware
of when things are pulling me in that
direction where most people wouldn't
understand it they would just feel
relaxed and they' feel drawn to it so I
just thought that was important to bring
about he has an app called howo that
he's constantly promoting for people to
join I'm your guide on hallow a prayer
and meditation app to help you find
peace take a deep breath in the name of
the father and of the son of the Holy
spirit amen this is a picture of Jesus
being stamped into the Public's mind and
him just naturally being Catholic is
going to make people they're going to be
more sympathetic to that St Padre Pi
said the greatest weapon against the
devil we have is the
rosary try it yeah he's encouraging
everybody to do the rosary which is
really saying a mantra right I mean it's
like a it's like a prayer that is a
scripted prayer that you say over and
over and over again right there's no
yeah we're not supposed to repeat
prayers that takes us into a a hypnotic
state so how powerful is that um he also
begins this by saying oh no it it was
the commercial where he's sitting in
Lotus position mind you and he's wearing
his prayer
beads um and then he says I'm your guide
on
hallow so this is your first
introduction to a guide yeah spirit
guide later so what about prayer beads
that what about that and what about the
Lotus position what is wrong with
that well it's just more of the Middle
Eastern kind of or the Eastern way of
praying or meditating I should say so
there's a Connecting Point with
meditation the prayer beads are cyclical
they're repetitive uh no different than
the rosary and then yes and then sitting
in that position and then actually
before he later in the commercial just
shortly after that clip that first part
of it he takes a deep cleansing breath
and then he starts to pray so that tells
you these three things right there tell
you this is contemplative prayer this is
not biblical prayer this is blanketed in
eastern philosophy yeah because I do I I
mean we've got a couple shows on on on
our channel uh some really solid shows
with that we did with guests who were
former yoga practitioners and they
talked about the yoga pose that yeah
it's like they they say yoga is not a
stretching it's a religion the the
Hindus see it as a religion it's just
the westerners who don't see it that way
and the Lotus pose is an act of worship
toward the Hindu gods not just
stretching mhm and it lacks humility you
know kneeling is a form of humility we
come to God to Jesus in need we know our
need and we know our helplessness that
position the Lotus position that is not
that so Jonathan quoted um father Padre
Pio talking about the power of the
Rosary praying the rosary so here we
read in prevailing prayer nothing else
so enrages Satan or so surely prevails
against him Earnest fervent prayer
causes Satan's whole host to tremble and
Retreat though we belong to a defeated
race Satan our conqueror is a defeated
foe this is the power of biblical prayer
you you tap into all of Heaven and uh
you know the the devil knows how
powerful prayer is so he he needs to
introduce something that is like you
know going to fill that space because he
can't get around the the the fact that
Christianity has recognized that there's
power in prayer yeah and so then he just
offers this other thing that kind of
supplements it but doesn't necessarily
tap into it so Stephanie I have a
question for you um I know the Bible
says don't pray in vain repetitions like
the Heathen do so in other word doing
this kind of prayer with vain
repetitions is is Pagan that's what the
Bible is basically saying but so um what
what's do you know what the origin of
that because I know you you practice a
lot of these prayers what is the origin
the pagan origin or Pagan roots of of
repetitious prayers well I would look at
Hinduism
Buddhism um shamanism
wow that would mostly focus on Buddhism
probably so yeah and that's pray beads
too there are a lot of other religions
that have prayer
beads so Protestants don't use prayer
beads typically we're about one of the
only religions that doesn't and I think
that also goes back to if you watch
Revelation the bride the beast in
Babylon you'll see and and this is
absolutely not a slam on Catholic
Brothers and Sisters in Christ this is
not a slam on them but the origin of the
Roman Catholic Church it was um
Babylonian that tradition right religion
that trickled down over time as multiple
nations conquered then Meo Persia came
in then Greece and then Rome and then
that Roman tradition religion paganism
started blending with Christianity which
over a long period of time formed the
Roman Catholic Church and it's really
sad to say that it's really sad to hear
that when you are a devout Roman
Catholic but that's the reality of it
yeah and so that's where these things
come from it's Pagan the the the church
did not start out as that the church
actually was the vehicle that God had
the not a the early church the biblical
church early church yes this was this
was a church that was formed by the
disciples and then moving into uh
history it just gotten basically taken
over yes and then steered in a different
direction but there's something that I
want I want to um highlight here the
reason why repetitive prayer is
problematic because then it puts in your
hands you're the answer to prayer did I
say that 50 times or did I say that a
100 times salvation by works and if I
say it 50 times um it's not as powerful
as if I say it a 100 times well who put
that power in that prayer yeah now that
power is taken and robbed from God and
it's now I'm doing something that is
basically causing the outcome of this
thing prayer is not like that at all
prayer is you recognizing you are a
helpless individual that is lost and has
zero power outside of Jesus whatsoever
and if something's going to transform
it's God's power that transforms you not
how many times you said that that's
right and God asks us to be fervent in
our prayer yeah I mean it's it's because
because God wants us to have a
relationship with him and so the
examples in the Bible of like the the
woman the parable of the woman who came
to the king and and came multiple times
it's not because well uh let me keep
check here uh yeah 10th time okay now
I'll give it to you it's more like like
the more you ask about the more like God
please help me I need you and it's like
gets the greas exactly it's like okay
now that you've really seen your need
for me and you really trust me and
surrender to me God can come through
it's a character building process during
the prayer process it's not hey let me
check the box you've done this 50 times
I'll reward you more kind of a thing and
I think that God treats us like that and
and operates like that because honestly
if every single time you ask for
something and all of a sudden it
happened people would then begin to
treat God like a Genie in a Bottle or
like a gumball machine I need this thing
so if I just say this to him he's going
to give it to me and and immediately and
that breaks down the relationship
exactly it's the same as in a marriage
right you're married I'm married
Stephanie's married so if if you uh
approach your spouse and you just stand
there and like man I really really want
my spouse to I don't know let's say my
Box's hurting I really want a massage hm
how can I get that uh if it give her $50
she'll probably do it or he'll probably
do it you know like it's like but no
that's not how it works it's love it's
relationship right good points he also
wants to build our faith in that waiting
time you know do you trust my promises
are you gonna you know how's your faith
so he's building our faith he's working
his um he's building he's what's the
word I don't know how to say it but
sanctification that is part of it too
that's how our characters are changed
that's righteousness by faith right
taking those
promises and believing them okay in
spirituality and contemplative prayer um
in spirituality is that Divinity or God
is in all things and the presence of God
is in all religions there is a
connecting together of all things
through mysticism I.E meditation which
we have learning we have learned today
the state of divinity can be
recognized and this is brought forward
in the catechism they are in agreement
and let's see one of the quotes from the
catechism is that we have become
Christ um another one is that so that he
may be man he that that he made man
might make men Gods wow there it is
right there all the way back to the tree
of knowledge of Good and Evil that you
will be as God if you do this the more
you contemplate the more you go in the
you will goes your godhead your God
person will be develop that goes back to
the original lie and it's like you know
becoming God and becoming Christ you
know that that spans into so much
Eastern philosophy you can see how that
influence just came from the East right
there mhm and that's where they got it
in the mid 300s Century um
the Middle Eastern or the Eastern U
people who practice meditation would
when they would sell their wees they
would travel to sell their wees they
would stay in these monasteries in the
deserts and then they taught they taught
the mystics or you know the monks
meditation so then the monks put um
contemplative prayer spin to it they
adopted it and then called it prayer
okay so here we we have a little um
thing from hallow from the the prayer of
examine the Jesuit examine which I was
introduced to you introduced to in
spiritual formation this is on their app
and it's a daily prayer uh you can
combine it with with lint but it's
supposed to be done daily in the evening
primarily it's basically a review of
your day um but it has the the verbage
of um like what did I do wrong and
conviction and repentance but it doesn't
really lead you in that direction
basically you just look review your day
as a whole and then um then you start
meditating but this is what they tell
you this was actually from my spiritual
formation days I had still had this so I
brought it
Forward uh they tell you to you thank
God for what he's done uh and then you
um ask him to Enlighten your mind about
any sins so basically you review your
day what what went well today what
didn't do well today where did I mess up
what did I not do that I should have
done what good did I not do that I
should have done there's nothing about
repentance or Lord forgive me help me to
be a better person tomorrow than today
um work in my life to change me to to
rid me of the sin nothing like that it's
just you review your day and then you
move into contemplation which we know um
the the Holy Spirit can't even speak to
you there so it has the appearance of
something but it's nothing it's dead
works and then they offer Leo deina on
the app which is divine reading and you
again dead works you read a short
passage and you read it over three times
you emphasize different words and then
whatever word or words pop up to you
then you take those words into
contemplative prayer so you've just
extracted scripture or words from um the
context and how are we just supposed to
study the Bible line upon line precept
upon precept compare scripture with
scripture so then you're going to take
that into contemplative prayer and
you're going to get a very different
meaning and
context you rewrite the Bible
interesting wait how how so cuz if
you're asking if you're asking for the
spirits to come in I mean this is
correct me if I'm wrong but this is what
I'm kind of understanding if you're
asking this spirits to come in and
you're in this contemplative prayer
state of mind this Alpha brain wave
pattern you know you're kind of opening
up but not necessarily thinking about it
right now you're talking about
repetitiously taking something and then
extracting something out of the context
and then asking for the interpretation
of that from different entities the
combination of all those things together
can then reinterpret what that thing
means for yeah because who is speaking
to you if it's not God who is okay so
now we're gon to move
into Andrew Garfield
and he was in the movie The Silence
where he played a a Jesuit priest um and
he talks
about how he well his he was involved in
the exercises for about a year we'll
hear that and then this is a clip where
he talks about what happened after his
silence his week of silence and we'll
just let him tell you you did a week of
of of uh uh silence right silent Retreat
yeah myself and Adam together we we
didn't really know each other very well
at that point and he kind of arrived two
days after me and we kind of just waved
to each other and what's the first thing
you said to each other when you could
first when like after a week when you
you haven't able to talk and you haven't
really met before what's the first thing
you said to each other after a week of
Silence yeah so we had these seven days
and it was so full of this kind of you
know Divine attempt to pray and to
meditate and to get close to those deep
inner voices and the spiritual kind of
exploration we were doing and I think we
got into the car and it was as if the
devil in both of us said where the have
you been because we just had the most
disgusting dirty awful dark conversation
for 3 hours on the way to the airport
because we we' had this in it like it
was like the devil felt so left out of
the last seven days that he just came
and made us say the most like nasty I
can't even remember I've like blocked it
out we just we went to the darkest place
for about 3 hours I mean that's that's
pretty telling in
itself right there that uh the fruits of
the spirit are not like that if you
spend time with God Moses did come down
off of the mountain with a glowing face
after spending time with God literally
talking to him face to face like a man
the devil is not part of that
conversation he's left out of that and
Moses did not come down just start
cussing his face was lit because he was
spending time with God and the fruits of
the spirit are peace love joy patience
goodness Temperance you know I mean if
you not experiencing those pieces of
fruit you got to question What Spirit
did you just hang out with and also the
Bible says by beholding we become
changed if we W if we behold Jesus we
become more like him but if we behold
something else and that's not just a
Biblical concept it's a it's a
scientific concept um you've heard of
mirror neurons it's it's it's it's
literally the idea or not the idea it's
scientifically proven that we have
mirror neurons in our brain that if can
you lift up your hand so my brain can't
tell the difference between you lifting
up your hand or a neuron firing in my
brain that I just did that like it's
mirroring in my brain so if he was there
and this comes out the week after then
during that week what was he mirroring
or what was he learning or beholding
that made him act like that mhm that's
very true I used to go on silent
Retreats and um you know I knew what I
was reading I was spending a lot of time
in contemplative prayer I mean hours and
my friends told me when I came out they
said Steph we never saw the fruit mean
the fruit of the spirit they never saw
the fruit of the spirit and um uh
interestingly enough when I started to
wake up from the things that I was
involved in I was reading a book I think
it's called the ragma gospel I think
it's by Brendan Manning I'm not sure I
have to go back and look
but in
there they used God's name in vain and I
thought why would you do that and then
my spiritual not my spiritual but my my
mentors in my spiritual Direction
programming uh they one of the ladies
started cussing she used God's name in
vain never blinked never apologize
nothing and so that's when the crack
started to happen to me I started to see
a different kind of fruit it took a long
time to see it but yeah so very
revealing as you said Scotty it was the
power of prayer that wielded the sword
of the spirit in the great Protestant
reformation and thus changed the history
of the world the prayer of faith is the
great strength of the Christian Warrior
and I just bring that forward again
because this is how important authentic
prayer is the picture on the screen for
this video the thumbnail was of Martin
Luther and um lyola so you have two
different they're contemporaries you
have two different paths they were both
monks and then are both Catholic and
then one chose the Bible in prayer
biblical prayer and started a
reformation and the other one chose um
you know the exercises that they were
actually given to him in a vision and he
chose contemplative prayer and uh he did
not choose solo scripture like Martin
Luther did so what we do makes it
difference as to where we're going to
end up all right so here's a quote from
hallow about sa St uh sister uh Teresa
or sa I guess they probably saying did
her Teresa of Aila she lived in the
1500s and she was she practiced
contemplative prayer she said
contemplative prayer in my opinion is
nothing else than an intimate sharing
between friends it means taking the time
frequently to be alone with him who we
know loves us and this is what I was
told about contemplative prayer just an
intimate time with with Jesus uh who
wouldn't want that
but I bring this forward because okay
she was steeped in contemplative prayer
and
then you have someone else this is Maria
DEA she was also known as the Blue Nun
she lived about the same time 15
1600s okay so 1600 early 1600s and she
also practiced contemplative prayer she
was a Franciscan nun I believe yes and
they the franciscans are especially
steeped in contemplative prayer so when
you look at our current pope he was from
a Franciscan order he's big in a
contemplative prayer and that's why he
chose Pope
Francis giv you their
agenda yep yep and and we saw earlier
when I was um sharing some of these
slides from my presentation I guess um
yeah that like like you saying Stephanie
he he he was a contemplative prayer kind
of guy uh so interesting so you can see
the results of her contemplative prayer
uh was
bilocation so she would be in Spain and
also be overlooking New Mexico or be
seen in New Mexico at the same time kids
would talk about how they would see her
and she was always in blue that's why
they called her the Blue
Nun wow so this is a mystical experience
right so they were contemporaries
practicing the same
thing now we're going to talk about what
uh a
longterm experience in contemplative
prayer can look like and something um
there's something called um Dark Knight
of the soul John of the Cross talks
about this in his book and that's when
you feel this sep separation between you
and God and you don't hear from him
anymore and really you're challenged
with um um this is where they apply
Faith do you have the faith to show up
even if you think he
doesn't right if he's not going to show
up are you still going to show up and do
your contemplative prayer and is that
going to be your offering for him
yourself every
day and so they experience this dryness
and emptiness of of the understanding
and
abandonment and this is what uh Mother
Teresa experienced for years a dark
light of the Soul
she also had Spirit guides uh top right
it says for few knew that she had been
guided all these years by apparitions
and a voice heard one summer long ago
this is where these are all mystical
experiences and we know they're not from
God because this is not of God it's not
scriptural yeah and that's that's the
thing that hallow calls it self your
your guide uh and and Jonathan roomy
says I will be your guide and then when
you look at these people that what
they're actually into is the Spirit
guides mhm which is totally a cult mhm
and we'll see more of that later we're
going to see some connecting pieces so
for those who don't understand
contemplative prayer maybe this is their
first time of hearing anything about it
we have a couple quotes one is from
Richard Foster who wrote celebration of
discipline he says that meditation is a
good way to obtain a consistent Alpha
Brain wve pattern so we're looking at an
Alpha Brain Wave you and I are in bet
right now we're thinking we're
Discerning we're like this stuff is you
know why why why I'm thinking why did I
do this for so long how did I not see
this is discernment right we can we can
think and judge critically in Alpha it's
a it's a hypnotic state I'm alert I know
what's going on but my frontal lobe is
shut down MRI studies show that um
there's decreased blood flow in the
frontal lobe when you're in Alpha yeah
it's a high it's a highly suggestible
state but Alpha is not always bad like
if you're sitting next to a creek and
you're relaxed enjoying God's creation
you can go into Alpha but it's it's bad
when you are in a a place or an
experience when you're emptying your
mind and having it empty where something
else can come in and then what is coming
in or what is being suggested to you
it's the same as when you watch movies
your mind goes into a suggestible state
and then any message through the system
can come in so uh Lori Abit who is a
witch in her book The Power of the witch
said the science of Witchcraft is based
upon our ability to enter Altered States
Of Consciousness we call Alpha in Alpha
the Mind opens up to non-ordinary forms
of communication okay okay non
non-ordinary forms that's a good point
well who are you well who are you
speaking to I mean you're empty your
mind and then this person says now you
can speak with in non-ordinary forms of
communication I mean what would a witch
be talking about but she's saying this
is what happens to Alpha and Alpha is
using contemplative prayer and that's
what a hallow app is using and so if you
play pray for the through the Hallow app
as genuine as you might be as genuinely
you might want to connect to God what
are you opening yourself up to Alpha
shuts off the frontal lobe and you
basically are kind of operating off of
your um lyic system your emotional
system right which just fight or flight
and emotions and your frontal loob is in
charge of Discerning it's your morality
your will your your your conscious
making decision processes so if you're
bypassing that and opening up the mind
and then something's communicating to
yeah you're not communicating and we
speak to God in our frontal lobe yes
that's why he said come let us reason
together he wants your reasoning mind to
engage in a relationship with him not
just your animalistic side of your brain
yeah and he doesn't want to just bypass
like I said the front of lobe and then
just hypnotize you into relationship
with him right that that's pretty deep
that is really deep right and Alice
Alice a Bailey's um gonna explain what
what that is in a little bit so um okay
so uh Lor cat also says Alpha is a
springboard for all psychic and magical
workings it's the heart of Witchcraft so
this is Alpha and this is what witches
um which is what witches practice
so Andrew Garfield just recently this
was October this year uh he just prior
to sometime in October he broke up with
his girlfriend who is a
witch so he dated this woman who is a
witch after his
conversion experience after his um week
of Silence after his year of spiritual
exercises and a spiritual director yeah
he just jumped into with a witch
literally there's also the yeah Statue
of Mary behind her but she's a
witch that's
interesting this is yeah you can be
Catholic and a witch don't you
know you can be this is the syncretism
it's universalism you can be all things
and still be called Christian have a
picture of the pope now this this just
came out um this month well October
while while we were putting this program
together and I was so excited to find
this this is a a youth function where
the pope attended and he carried a
witch's
Stang so what is a stay it's basically
is for Conjuring wow and you just think
about this about the staff and and you
know it's like the pope is always seen
with the cross right so now it's like
you're seeing him with this sort of
Witchcraft tool yeah yeah he's wearing
the Hat of Deon which was like you said
it was in honor of a fish God back in
the Heyday mhm he's also having the
cross of Malta on his robe here in the
middle which um is the military order of
of the Freemasons isn't it or is it the
Catholics I think it all stems back from
Catholicism as well but but it is a
military version of it yeah yeah the
military version of the Freemasonry but
yes yeah we already established the
Freemasonry comes from this yeah yeah so
I I think uh Walter V has a whole show a
whole series on from Malta to do you
remember what from to Malta cre to Malta
yeah because wasn't it in Malta that the
Freemasons were really active something
like that yeah it's been a while since
I've seen that one but that's a really
good one cre Mal I'll put a link in the
description right here another one would
be good to put under there is um the
secret behind the secret
societies makes that
connection so I mean in the write up uh
write up that I was reading a Catholic
was per he was just perplexed he said
why would a Catholic use a Stang and I'm
thinking Catholic means Universal it's
totally appropriate and when you put it
in that context this is
interspirituality syncretism same thing
mhm and also the origins of the Roman
Catholic church if you go way back it's
Babylonian going to MEAP Persia which
was the next nation that take took over
the world Empire then Greece and then it
came down to Rome which came down to the
Roman Church so these two Jesuits the
you and Adam Driver play these two
Jesuits who are deeply tested their
faith is deeply tested because they're
captured by the Japanese who trying to
rid a Japan of of Christians at the time
did you have to study like did you study
to be a Jesuit I studied with a a mutual
friend of ours I studied with a a mutual
friend of ours Father James Martin who
used to he was the chapl of the cber
nation years and someone that I love as
dearly as you seem to and he um I
studied with him for a year and I went
through the um ignatian spiritual
exercises and actually I found out that
stanislavsky who invented modern acting
the method of Modern acting that
resulted in the American method and
everything after that was deeply
inspired by St ignatius' spiritual
exercises so I felt kind of right at
home Andrew what's the trick
to Bringing across the idea of the
American South and the accent while
you're shooting in Sydney we were
talking about mystery earlier and how
the and the process of absorbing
Desmond's Essence and attempting to
ingest him so so I stay in the act all
the time to not confuse myself mostly
was pry the depth of Soul uh there's
also I think he wasn't a talker Desmond
and Andre is able to convey very much
without the need of dialogue as an actor
I mean you can just see into his eyes
and stuff it's all going
on so I mean I his talents I think and
he's very talented just suited this
character and then I wasn't disappointed
at all he's managed to inhabit Desmond
or Desmond inhabited him I'm not sure
which I think there was some both going
on that there there was a a particularly
profound moment where I went to um
Chattanooga Tennessee which is where
Desmond eventually retired and passed
away and I went onto his old property um
and went into his old wood wood Woodshed
and handled his tools and walked around
the lake that he would walk around and
it was I spent a day there just kind of
praying and and and asking like just
guide me through this if you can hear me
tell like tell me tell me what to do
tell me how to move tell me to speak
tell me how to behave and I'll do
whatever you say so that there was some
there was a a strange mysterious
spirituality going on around the the
making of This film telling clip right
there yes he's telling you that method
acting is basically the same as the
spiritual exercises It Felt Like Home to
him and then when he prayed and we know
that that's contemplative prayer
Alpha
then um he was asking for him to
help him to do things so he opened his
mind to another Spirit wow so in other
words what Hall is teaching what is it
opening you up to again yes um now we
have another another example of that
really with Jonathan roomy before he
played Lonnie frisbee he went and did
basically grave soaking he laid on his
laid beside his grave and he just prayed
and he's like you know if I'm supposed
to do this let me know and he was trying
to absorb some things from him so this
is consistent and it's not uh they're
they're both Catholic they don't have a
problem with it so there's no problem
with that because the Dead Aren't Dead
and then um and then as a method actor
that's what they've learned so he
actually went and sought out where
Lonnie frisbee was buried and this was
scary what he did before I started work
I went over to Christ Cathedral
and uh I I sat by his grave and I prayed
a rosary with him I sat down and I
prayed with him um the the the space
just to his right is empty so I got to
sit down or lie at one point I even lied
down because I just thought it would be
kind of interesting to try to connect in
some way that's probably more
information than you need or may want to
publish but that said uh you know I it's
the truth and so I finished praying with
him
I said Lonnie I want to honor you with
this
film and I really want to um to to to
bring Justice and and you know the
Testament to the gifts of God's grace
and and powers that you you know
displayed while you were on this Earth
and
so if this is a good idea that I do this
film have somebody Give Me A Sign Give
Me A Sign have God give me a sign and
the minute the words left my mouth
behind me there was a door open to the
cathedral and this giant cord rang out
for about 5 seconds and then from the
organ from the organ wow I hadn't heard
it before and that's the very organ that
used to be there when it was the C it's
the same organ that when it was the
Crystal Cathedral mhm it was sent out
and refurbished and whatnot but it's the
same one so I heard that and I was
like okay thanks for that when you're
asking and you know and you're not
asking God you're asking a dead person
you're literally telling the spirit
world hey I want you to show me
something show me something that's going
to convince me and he got that answer
when he heard the organ play he was like
all right thank you for that who was he
thanking he wasn't thinking a dead man
he's been dead for years but he was
actually thanking the demons that gave
him the sign Jesus actually said that
it's an adulterous and wicked nation
that looks for signs and wonders
there's an important thing that we need
to understand about the state of the
Dead MH there's a lot of communication
that's going on here in in in
Catholicism if somebody is basically
feeling like they need to communicate
with with somebody that so quote unquote
was on God's side or whatever right and
you're sitting down asking for that
Spirit to manifest themselves so that
you can somehow have some Communications
right uh I believe that the Bible
teaches that the dead know not not
anything Ecclesiastes um 96 right and so
so when you die you are dead until the
second coming because it says that the
dead in Christ will be raised at that
time right so you got to be really
careful inviting spirits to come
communicate with you that are dead yeah
yeah and we have a whole series on a
channel called Hot Seat in which we
delved into some of these major
questions on death are they really dead
are they not and you know you've heard
us talk a lot about the uh pagan origins
uh that have seeped into Christianity
through Catholicism and this is one of
them and I know a lot of people will
disagree with me I'm telling you look
into this truthout death.com and ghost
truth.com and helltruth.com are really
good resources that literally show you
scripture by scripture common scriptures
people use they debunk them and we've
debunked them in our hot seed series on
YouTube so check that out okay so
spiritualism on that note the belief or
doctrine that the spirits of the Dead
surviving after the Mortal
life can um can and do communicate with
the living especially through a person a
medium particularly suceptible to their
influence so now we know how they become
susceptible to their influence because
of what we've seen so far now we're
going to move into the occult because
you cannot touch on this stuff without
um bringing it to the occult because
that's where it lands all right and it's
interesting here found in the letters of
Mother Teresa it says this stage of
contemplation is reached when we make
contact with the soul now their
understanding of soul is that it's a
separate entity right we believe the
body and the the breath make up a soul
but you remove one and then you don't
have a soul but for the
most Mo most of the population believe
in a soul that exist Never Dies so they
make contact with the soul through the
soul we have access to all knowledge
past present and future when we make
contact with the soul we have we also
have the ability to communicate
telepathically with the souls of others
as Alice Bailey put it in her I'm using
quotes here because I'm not saying this
wonderful book from intellect to
intuition the Mind receives illumination
from the soul in the form of ideas
thrown into it or of
intuitions and that's from spiritual
telepathy so that's what happens beings
from past present and future drop
thoughts in our minds according to B so
the ability to enter the subtle Worlds
at will is the high prize and ultimate
goal of esoteric training this
development will allow us to access the
mind of God and direct directly register
what the Bible calls the pattern of the
things in Heavens the blueprint of the
cosmos uh this simply it's just an
ongoing quote from Bailey now if you're
not clear on clear on this this is
talking about the cosmic Christ we will
then understand and be able to to
participate consciously in the great
plan for Humanity Bailey addressed this
step when she wrote one after another
the Sons and Daughters of God have
entered into their Heritage and found
themselves sensitive to the world
plan they have through steadfastness and
comp contemplation equip themselves to
act as interpreters of the Universal
Mind quote look at this U is capital M
is capital this is the mind of Satan and
as intermediaries between the non-
telepathic multitude and the Eternal
Foundation of wisdom well it's just kind
of a bit of a counterfeit because you
know we are called to have the mind of
Christ let this mind be put in you that
was also in Christ Jesus right and and
um but it's like adding God mind to us
not that we are then going into God's
mind and searching his purposes if that
makes sense I think there's a difference
between the two of those things David
said search me search my heart not like
let me search you God yeah she also goes
on to say the new era is coming the new
ideals the new civilization the new
modes of Life of Education of religious
presentation and of government are
slowly precipitating and not can stop
them they can however be delayed by the
reactionary types of people by the ultra
conservative I.E
fundamentalist and closed minds they are
the ones who can and do hold back the
hour of Liberation these must all be
brought under the power of
death we have an occultist in agreement
with um Tom not Thomas keing um car
raner yeah the Jesuit I was going to say
that same thing yeah you don't think
like us you should be dead mhm
now here is a clip about the Jesuits and
how
it how they have a dead conscience has
anyone fasted has anyone gone through
like a fast or yeah and it's a beautiful
spiritual process cuz you the idea is
you empty out in order for Spirit to
enter okay so where this all leads you
the je the mind of a Jesuit is you your
conscience becomes deadened from
practicing something that's void of the
holy spirit so you're going to grieve
that Holy Spirit and then you're just
going to be basically die inside um
you're not going to know right from
wrong you're not going to feel guilt uh
so
then the other thing they want you to do
is question everything they don't want
you to question what they tell you if
they tell you something is is black when
it's white you're supposed to believe it
right don't question that but here
you're going to see a clip of Andrew
talking about how he doubts everything
and that a life of faith is a life of
doubt and that's what I learned in
spiritual formation it was this is very
much a a um prevalent prominent teaching
you knew that there was an afterlife
would that be comforting or terrifying
how would I ever know I don't know but
it's that but but I what what I mean is
is a visitation from an angel how about
that well sure but I would always
question it even after a visitation I
would always I think it's healthy you
think about Thomas Merton the great
Trappist sure Monk and and philosopher
really um his his doubt was his greatest
Ally I he was always constantly doubting
and I think a life of faith is not a
life of certainty a life of faith is a
life of of doubt it is a sad State of
Affairs that you read philosophy yeah
that you read the Bible and it's giving
you assurance that your Assurance of
being in Jesus Christ is that you have
life and you have it you know like God
says you know if you have me you have
eternal life and so I think if you read
the words of the Bible you can say
without you know doubting there is an
afterlife 100% claim the promises that's
what this whole thing is about this is
what we're trying to do I I I know
without a shadow of my doubt there is
probably nothing that can be said in
this conversation or any conversation
that would remove that from my mind like
there is definitely a God and a Satan
and they are at War and there is an
afterlife and I know that from reading
the scriptures and seeing the Miracles I
am not doubting that doubt is how we got
to this in the first place doubting God
going I don't know did he really say
Don't eat this fruit that's how we
started this Con that's how we started
this whole messing to begin with that's
right and you know we're looking at a a
prayer and meditation app and if prayer
is part of the sanctifying process uh
also is Bible reading and when we pray
we pray the scriptures those those
promises into our lives over our lives
and the word that is living
is then it transforms us so if you don't
take those promises by faith we will not
live a life of
sanctification and we will not develop
the character that we're supposed to
develop that God wants us to develop so
that we can be in heaven what I say when
I what I mean when I say certainty
scares me certainty starts War certainty
starts war on behalf of ideology
certainty of the I I I know and you
don't that's the scariest thing to me in
what a human being is capable of doing
he didn't he wouldn't have liked my
comment then he totally encapsulates the
postmodern mindset my truth your truth
you know we cannot be we cannot have
absolute truth also the the pope who is
again the Jesuit Pope Francis he writes
very badly of people he calls
fundamentalists fundamentalists are
people like you me you Stephanie who
believe in Solas scriptura the word of
God and the word of God alone and I will
stand by what the word says if the word
says God created the world in six days
and rested on the seven then that that's
how long it took for him to make the
world it's not like 6,000 years or
something like that that's a
fundamentalist but but again this goes
against that idea like you cannot have
certainty therefore you should not take
the word as it is so let me give you a
piece of certainty so anybody else
that's in this Universal mindset of um
of uh what's the term for this when your
like um relativism or whatever you know
what like you may see it that way um the
wages of sin is death please share with
me how that is not a certain
term you can't make it anything that is
a 100% certain term you sin you die like
nobody other than Jesus and even Jesus
submitted to death nobody is going to
sin and live unless they are covered
with the blood of Jesus exactly so like
certain Moses and Elijah and Enoch but
were covered by the blood of Jesus yes
so there is a lot of certainty not
doubting that but I wonder if that's
included in the H app here we have
Jonathan roomy first I want to point out
his shirt right and this is this quote
has to do with the Eucharist people say
it's a symbol this is his response to
people saying it's a
symbol again as a Christian I would feel
very uncomfortable wearing that shirt
now let's see what he has to say when
when he enters the stage and it is my
honor to welcome Jonathan roomy this
evening
wow
wow oh my
gosh oh my God
that that was enough I mean he uses
God's name in vain he uses God's name in
vain when he walks out that's the first
thing that this the audience hears I
mean it's just like what are you what
what no well I think also the other
thing is that that people worship him
yeah they literally make him an idol
yeah it's a real fine blurred line
because they see him as Jesus because of
the production and so it's like people
have said and commented when we pray we
we are picturing him in our minds when
people read the Bible they're picturing
him in their Minds like that's just way
too bluring the line there okay so in
this clip we have Jars of Clay who
composed music for The Chosen let's see
what he has to say about Jesus I think
when they see this version of Jesus
portrayed he has his own flaws in a
human way like he's very relatable and
um and gracious and I think people need
to see that that side of Jesus cuz we've
a lot of us have been force-fed
um you know a a version of Jesus that
only cares about our behaviors every
episode the story pushes back on that
yeah it has nothing to do with with
obedience right yeah I think it's
interesting that this is this is
Jonathan the who was in playing Jesus in
The Chosen that's what made him so
popular and now he's in the Hallow app
having this kind of a portrayal that
they're trying to put out a flawed kind
of Jesus and now you're supposed to use
him the flock kind of Jesus for your
meditations to supposedly come closer to
the real Jesus yeah that doesn't make
sense
yeah I think he said when in the
beginning uh towards the beginning he
was saying something and now we have a
Jesus more like me or something like
that so we don't want someone who we
want to Aspire to or towards we want
someone who looks like me I I want me
reproduced it's almost like bringing
Jesus down to our level rather than
bringing us up to Jesus's level you know
what I mean like like Jesus Jesus did
come down right and and he went through
the same experience that we have so he
dealt with you know depression and
feeling with you know like the feelings
that we have because he's able to secure
us is how the Bible says it right he
went through that experience then
therefore we can go oh wow he identifies
with us but he did not come down and and
have flaws and he's just like me like
flawed like me you know what I mean he
was sinless he was sinless and he's
fully God and fully man in a sinless
body or a sinful body so to say but did
not commit human body yeah he had the
propensities passed down to him through
his human side yeah he had real
temptation but he never gave into the
Temptation that's right that's right
he's not flawed so in these two clip not
they're not Clips just pictures we have
him wearing the Hallow app and smoking a
cigar while he's out on the golf course
and then we have Mark wallberg who also
promotes the hell app and who's very
Catholic um he always says stay prayed
up he's promoting alcohol he has
invested or owns an alcohol um brand and
he goes out and he he even will serve
alcohol at a bar to promote his well
that's one way to bring the spirit into
the situation right aad bad joke
and then here we have him uh he's doing
a live he just goes live sometimes he's
coming home from the gym and here we go
tuna whoa
yeah hell yeah
Min week cheffy is going to
[Music]
town
okay wow bleep that yeah wow that I mean
yeah you know know it's it's it's it's
interesting that you you you know I I
remember I went through a phase of
cussing when I was like in the world and
stuff like that when I came back out
that was one of the first things that
that God really cleared up was my
language if you're prayed up right you
and you're you know you're all like
connected to God it's just like I didn't
want to say those words anymore I
remember I became a Christian when I was
16ish a
teenager and and I remember being you
know everybody in my high school knew I
was a Christian now and and I was
actually using God's name in vain and I
felt this conviction I was like no no no
no I can't say that anymore I felt
horrible not because I'm a good person
it's because the Holy Spirit speaks to
you but I think maybe I'm guessing
Stephanie the point you're trying to
make with this is that if when you come
closer to God and he convicts you and he
works on your heart that's when he
points you in this Direction that's when
he brings you closer to him and that's
when you want to stop doing this I mean
my husband before he became a Christian
I don't know he was like 32 33 when
became a Christian he he was cussing
like a sailor he was doing drugs and
alcohol and the whole thing and and he
said as soon as he became a Christian it
was overnight he stopped cussing and
everybody around him was like what what
happened what what's going on why are
you not cussing anymore you know they
noticed something changed so it's the
holy spirit that that works that
Reformation in you amen and it it's very
revealing of the spirit that is working
um in through contemplative prayer and
and these practices so again Martin
Luther and lyola you have two different
directions two different paths two
different sources and two different
characters all right so sanctifying
prayer prayer is Heaven's means of
success in overcoming sin now this is a
Prayer app and we're seeing the fruit of
this prayer app or people who engage in
these practices on The Prayer app I
should say uh it's a sanctification that
comes through obedience to the
truth through faith every deficiency of
character may be supplied every
defilement cleansed every fault
corrected every Excellence developed
what a contrast that's beautiful and and
just to clarify this is not a quote that
came from the hollow
app yeah just so people don't get
confused this is an actual quote from a
a beautiful book The the one you've been
quoting from right prayer it's a
different book than prevailing prayer
prevailing prayer I think was by Murray
um or moody moody this is from one of my
favorite authors and then to end with a
Bible verse that he might present to
himself a glorious church not having
spot or wrinkle or any such thing but
that it should be holy and without
blemish this is what God wants to do in
our lives so amen which kind of prayer
do you believe is going to do this for
you biblical prayer amen what that the
prayers that Jesus prayed himself which
was not contemplative prayer or any of
these other prayers no that are
unfortunately DED in uh paganism and
occultism and mysticism which is not
from God yeah it's unfortunate that even
the Lord's Prayer he did not give us
that prayer that that prayer should be
repeated over and over and over and
because of the repeating of that prayer
it somehow has power yeah if you can use
the name of Jesus in a repetitive Manner
and it's and it's bad
right if you're just like saying a
mantra and focusing on the word of Jesus
because in the New Age isn't that kind
of what you do right when contemplative
prayer and centering prayer and all that
kind of stuff you can take a single word
even the word of Jesus yeah and that and
and and I believe there's power in the
name of Jesus but in that con context
and the way it's used right you could
probably also take the Lord's Prayer and
use it out of context well and think
about it what do repetitions do you can
hypnotize yourself by doing that so I'm
thinking that's probably why God said
don't pray like the heathens do which is
repetitions yeah and he was giving us an
example pray like this not necessarily
just like this is the thing that you
need to repeat over and over and over
again yep and as you were talking it hit
me a thought struck me um is repeating
the name of Jesus in that context using
his name in
vain probably I think there's a lot more
to just using using the name of Jesus in
as as a swear word or cuss word or like
the OMG or whatever like that right I
think that is using the lord's name in
vain but I also think there's other
applications where you call yourself a
Christian so you put this stamp of
Christianity on you and then you're
completely immoral if I went out and you
know was cussing like a sailor and and
cheating on my wife and all sorts of
stuff like this right but I'm calling
myself a Christian that's using the
lord's name in vain that's Christ's name
being tarnished by your actions of going
out and doing yeah and and we should
mention though there might be a lot of
people on here watching who are like
wait a minute but I I do these prayers
as a Catholic or I'm a Protestant may
but I've been using the hall app and
have done this kind of prayer with the
name of Jesus did I take the name of
Jesus in vain look God understands the
heart God sees how genuine people are
and how people just don't know and then
once we know God's like I got you it's
okay I forgive you now come to me and I
will teach you the biblical prayer that
builts a relationship with me that's why
Jesus said um or or I think it maybe is
Paul that God winked in is it Peter Paul
it's one of those that God Winks at our
ignorance yeah God Winks at our
ignorance because yeah you don't know
but once you know I mean really pray
about these things if you feel like you
know hey wow I was using this app
unawares and now yeah now you've
presented this information to you rather
than get upset and reject and whatever
like this just go you know what I'm
going to take this to the Lord in prayer
and I'm going to ask him to reveal the
truths of these things or impress upon
me whatever they we just watched in this
video right now is there truth in that
Lord show me and and there'll be a lot
of people in heaven who you know in the
past have have had this genuine they
triy to have a genuine relationship with
Jesus I mean think of the Dark Ages
right there was only one Church which
was the Roman Catholic church or we
should we say the Roman Universal Church
there's lots of people who might have
done all these things that were actually
Pagan who didn't know God's not going to
be like yeah sorry didn't know it's like
no you he judges according to light
that's been given you so there's lots of
people are going to be in heaven we
going to be Catholic and all kinds of
Christian faith who knows maybe they're
not even Christian but they lived
according to the light that was given
them but and that's why it says know God
Winks at our ignorance but once we've
been given the light the Bible says then
you should walk in the light then you
should walk in truth because then if you
don't that's when it's held we are held
accountable for it because the Book of
Revelation tells us come out of her my
people a false system of worship that
you be not partakers of her sins y there
would be no reason to say that if there
was not a reason to ask you to leave
that or come out of that that that you
are by being there you're partaking in
the sins that are accounted for this
Harlot the the woman that's sitting
there on the Beast that is a mixture of
false religions and false doctrines yes
riding the beast power which is like a
dragon which is the Bible tells us who
the dragon is right so the woman being a
symbol of the church sitting on Satan
really
and having a cup full of the mixtures of
doctrines yes but but everything that
God says to us like come out of her you
know um he's holding us accountable to
what we do know but wings that are
ignorance it's all encapsulated in his
love he is he wants us to have a loving
deep relationship with him a real
relationship God is not a God who just
sits there on his throne and zaps people
he is a God who says I love you I died
for you I gave myself for you so you
could come and spend eternity with me
and that's why he's saying please I I
want to have this real relationship with
you just like in a marriage where we're
not just like trying to check off a list
or trying to put a coin in a gumball
machine and then you know your spouse
starts moving it's like no you are back
and forth back and forth and real
genuine conversation that's what real
prayer is that's what God wants from us
good point well he also loves us enough
to give us a choice unlike what K rer
said and
blaty I mean Bailey um you will die
right you will do this or you will die
so a choice you know Jesus or God says
you know you choose choose you this day
whom you will serve um and we we have a
choice and he allows us to either choose
to retain sin in our lives and then we
will be destroyed by default because he
has to destroy sin yeah not because he
wants to but because we chose to he
always leaves the choice to us excellent
points if anybody has any um difficulty
with this topic if it hits home to them
and now they're facing a decision that's
really difficult for them because for me
it broke my heart to find out what I was
involved in and it was very difficult to
give it up it was ingrained in me it was
part of me and um I I doubted you know
leaving am I leaving God so no you are
not leaving God you are coming closer to
God if you leave these practices um
aside but if you need help if you need
encouragement meet me to pray with you
I'll be happy to do that I'll be happy
to help you walk walk you through it um
God is good he is faithful amen there
you have it out of the mouth of someone
who has personal experience in being led
down this path coming back out of that
um if you guys have questions on that or
you really want to know I mean genuinely
seeking really wanting to know where the
truth is in this please feel free take
her up on that communicate with her
we'll put a link in the description
below of how you guys can get a hold of
her but also share this video it really
really really helps us if you kind of
copy this link send it to somebody that
you would you would want to know or
write a comment in there if there's
something that was unclear and you want
to know something more please feel free
to communicate with us we want to not
leave you confused but we want to leave
you with more truth and so we are
willing to H take those comments very
seriously obviously be respectful please
and also um once again I want to say
this with with all honesty of our hearts
none of us here are attacking
Catholicism just to attack the people
part of Catholicism we're attacking a
system that has a long tradition of of
some of these things that we've brought
up every church has its problems but but
listen there is some real truths here
and um we don't want anyone walking away
from this conversation just feeling like
we're hating on them so yeah and
definitely the link in the description
too for the documentary Revelation the
bride the beast in Babylon check it out
for yourself um and I should also say
again I was uh baptized into a Roman
Catholic Church I was given a rosary
right so it's not like we are saying
this and we're just like well you guys
are just Protestants and you're just
hammering on like no honestly it comes
from from Stephanie having a background
in in Christian mysticism I have a
background having dabbled with
Catholicism
but having all come to the Protestant
faith that we believe is Sola scriptura
and we should also mention if you want
to dig deeper into the Bible go check
out our Bibles School L.T v/b School
Link in the description as well because
we encourage everybody don't listen to
anything we say check what we say with
the Bible and the word of God which is
the truth and the light and life if you
haven't done so like And subscribe this
video and we'll see you guys in the next
week
[Music]
[Applause]
there has been very few movies in the
history of the world that have
completely changed our world and in 1999
a movie titled The Matrix hit the world
stage these stories are often told and
seen over and over again is it simply
just to make money or is there something
more nefarious behind it
[Music]